[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اذا بعد مراسم عريقه تاريخيه
دينيه تم تتويج تشارلز الثالث ملكا
للمملكه المتحده وتوجد كامله ملكه مودعه
لقب الملك القرينه
[موسيقى]
مهمه وذات دلالات تاريخيه خلال تتويج
الملك الاربعين للمملكه المتحده تشارلز
الثالث
الان
تبدا العوده من
وسننسر الى قصر باكينغهام على متن هذه
العربه الملكيه الذهبيه التي بنيت عام
واستخدمت في كل مراسم التتويج منذ عام
هذه العربه مصنوعه من الخشب المكسو باوراق
الذهب
وعليها مجسمات الملائكه التي تمثل انجلترا
واسكتلندا ويلز
وايضا الواح مزينه بالرسومات
وهي ثقيله الوزن ويبلغ وزنها نحو اربعه
اطنان لذلك يتطلب جرها على الاقل ثمانيه
احصنه الان بدات الامطار تهطل في سماء
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
نتابع هذه الصوره
يشارك نحو اربعه الاف فرد من افراد القوات
المسلحه فيما وصف من قبل وزاره الدفاع
باضخم ظاهره احتفاليه من نوعها منذ جيل
مضى الحديث هنا عن سبعين عاما مضت عندما
تم تتويج الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه عام 53
ملكه لبريطانيا والان عن عمر 74 عاما يتوج
تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا
بعد ان امضى سبعين عاما في ولايه الاحد
محمد شبارو الصحفي من لندن ينضم الينا
صوره مهيبه مراسم
عريقه شهدناها خلال الساعات الماضيه
تعليقك على ما نشاهده في هذه الصوره
تحياتي لكم
ابرز ما هو ان اخيرا الملك تشارلز الثالث
قد لقي قدره يعني هو
ارتبط مصيره منذ ولادته بهذا اليوم تحديدا
واليوم
هو اعتلى العرش بعد طول انتظار ولكن ايضا
لابد من القول ان انه كان ينتظر هذا اليوم
بفارغ الصبر من دون شك بشكل او باخر
وهو تدرب على ايدي والدته الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه
ونحن نشهد اليوم يوم تاريخي ربما لن يتكرر
تتويج ملك اخر في بريطانيا نحن لا ندري
هناك طبعا مطالبات بان لا يكون هناك ملكيه
في بريطانيا ولكن هذه الاصوات ما تزال
خافته فنحن اليوم نشهد احدى الفعاليات
عظيمه والضخمه التي تنظم في بريطانيا بشكل
لا مثيل له في العالم اي ان برنامج الحفل
او الاستعراض والموكب والتفاصيل الصغيره
جدا قد تم التدرب على تنفيذها يوما بعد
يوم على مدى الاشهر الماضيه ونحن نشهد هذه
التظاهره العالميه عيون العالم اليوم كلها
على المال الطريق المؤدي الى قصر باكنجهم
فهو خرج منه ملكا غير متوج والان هو يعود
اليه وعلى راسه التاج وبيده الصولجان
الحكم واراده الحكم ولو كان رمزيا الا ان
دلالاته ومكانته مكانه العائله الملكيه في
بريطانيا الرمزيه ما تزال قويه رغم كل ما
يقال وما يتم التشكيك فيه عن ان
الشعب البريطاني او الجمهور البريطاني قد
اصبح
يهتم بالملكيه بشكل اقل الا انني اعتقد ان
دورها ما زال فاعلا
وايضا مكانتها خاصه جدا في قلوب
البريطانيين الذين يعني يحتفلون اذا كنت
تسير في شوارع لندن في هذا الاسبوع مثلا
لا تسمع لا تسمع حديثا سوى الحديث عن
فقط نعلق باننا نتابع الان انضم يبدو الى
الموكب الذي غادر كنيسه وسط مونستر ابناء
الامير ويليام ايضا جورج ولوي والاميره
شارلو تنضموا الى والدهم على متن هذه
العربه التي تسير خلف العربه الملكيه
الذهبيه هذا الموكب سيبلغ طوله اثنين
واثنين فاصله تسعه كيلو متر من الكنيسه
الى محيط القصر طبعا تم اختصاره كان ربما
اطول من ذلك في عهد
الملكه اليز عندما تم تتويجها ربما كان
اكثر من سته كيلو مترات وبالتالي
لكن هذا المشهد او هذه اللوحه محمد اذا
جاز التعبير التي تابعناها منذ الصباح
وحتى الان الى اي مدى ربما ستعزز حضور
المؤسسه الملكيه في المملكه المتحده وتقوض
ربما وجاهت مطالب مناهضي الملكيه في
بريطانيا واذا جاز للتعبير اود ان اسالك
من يناهض الملكيه في بريطانيا
تيار
الملكين
لننتظر واحد و
انا الملكيه راسخه في بريطانيا واليوم هي
بابها تجلياتها نزول الشعوب
المواطنين البريطانيين واصطفافهم لساعات
ولايام بالقرب من ممر مسيره موكب ملكهم
تشارلز الثالث هو ابرز عنوان او ابرز
دلاله على ان هؤلاء متمسكين
برمزيه ملكيتهم واسرتها الحاكمه نعم هناك
مطالب بين جماعات مختلفه بطول وعرض البلاد
ممن يعتقدون انه لا معنى للملكيه بعد
اليوم وانها تكلف دافعيه ضرائب اموالا
لتسيير هذه المؤسسه ولكن ما زالت هذه
الاصوات خافته استطيع ان اجزم بان التيار
هو تيار صغير حتى الان لا يشبه اي تيار له
وزن على الساحه السياسيه البريطانيه وان
كان صوتهم مسموعا واليوم راينا لقد قامت
الشرطه باعتقال عدد من هؤلاء المتحمسين من
اجل تاسيس الجمهوريه في بريطانيا ولكن لا
اعتقد ان ان لديهم اتباع او ان حجمهم كبير
قد لا يقول لك البريطاني انه مع الملكيه
ولكنه حين تساله هل تريد الغائها فانا لا
اعتقد ان الاجابات لدى الكثيرين او لدى
غالبيه الشعب قد تقول
لنتخلى عن الملكيه اليوم هناك احاديث في
الاوساط البريطانيه لطالما كانت عن جدوى
وضروره وعدم ضروره الملكيه ولكن اعتقد ان
الاغلبيه العظمى ما زالت تتمسك بهذا الان
سوره الامير هاري الذي حضر مراسم التتويج
دون زوجته واولاده الذين بقوا في
كاليفورنيا شاهدنا صوره ربما لم نشاهد
الكثير من الصور هذه ربما
اللقطه تم التقاطها الان بعد انتهاء مراسم
التتويج ربما
تتفق معي بانه اريد بان تكون هذه اللحظه
لحظه تشارلز الثالث فقط
اعتقد ان البروتوكول من دون شك كما لاحظنا
داخل الكنيسه لقد راينا الصوره مركزه او
عدسات الكاميرا مركزه على اخت شقيقه الملك
الاميره ان لقد راينا الامير ادوارد
وراينا بعض اخرين من افراد العائله
المالكه وكان هنا وهناك لمحات لجلوس
الامير هاري على في الصف الثالث ضمن
المواقع المخصصه للعائله الملكيه
لافرادها
واعتقد ان هذا بروتوكوليا قد تم تنظيمه كي
لا تتحول اللحظه الى لحظه
الجدل حول مشاركه وعدم مشاركه وغياب ماجن
ماركل دوقه
وانها لم تكن الى جانب زوجها المهم ان
هاري قد حضر اعتقد ان عزوف مساله عزوف
ماجن عن الحضور هي اعتقد شاهدنا سوره شقيق
والامير وليم مع عائلته في العربه
المرافقه والتي تتبع عربه
الملك العربه الذهبيه كنا نتحدث عن من
يناهض الملكيه لكن هذا يوحينا الى السؤال
يعني ما هي سلطات وصلاحيات الملك في
بريطانيا محمد
الملك يعني هو يجلس على العرش ولكن
سلطاته ويتراس البلاد ولكن سلطاته رمزيه
وتتحول سلطاته التنفيذيه كلها لرئيس
الوزراء وهو بشكل او باخر يعين رئيس
الحكومه ولكن نزولا عند طلب من البرلمان
بعد اي انتخابات وايضا يقبل استقالته نعم
هذا الوجود هو وجود رمزي
لراس السلطه في هذه في البلد ولكن هذا هو
العرف السائد منذ العام 1500 عندما سار
كرومويل على العرش وتحول بعد ذلك الى خفض
صلاحيات الملك وصولا الى يعني ان تتحول
مجلس النواب الى السلطه الحاكمه ورئيس
الحكومه هو من يحظى باغلبيه في مجلس
النواب ولكن
سلطات الملك
البريطاني رمزيه في اكثر من مكان في
الدوله البريطانيه اذ هو يعني بشكل او
باخر يتم التشاور معه بشكل اسبوعي من قبل
رئيس الحكومه ويدلي بدلوه في قضايا مختلفه
طبعا كل ملك له خصوصيته واهتماماته
المعينه سياسيا او اجتماعيا او ثقافيا او
حضاريا ولكن
الخيط ليس مقطوعا بين
مقر السلطه التنفيذيه في المملكه المتحده
وبين قصر باكينغ فاجتماعات اعتقد يوم
الاربعاء هي اجتماعات مجدوله لابد ان يجلس
ويتناول رئيس الحكومه الموجود بالسلطه
الشاي مع العاهل البريطاني شكرا لك محمد
تفضل بقاء معي ساعود لك لكن دعنا نشرك في
الحوار معنا مديره مكتب العربيه ريما
مكتبي ريما وانت تت ابعين هذه المشاهد
الجميله في لندن وهذه المراسم وكل هذه
الوفود والضيوف الذين جاؤوا لمشاركه الملك
تشارلز هذه اللحظه التاريخيه التي انتظرها
كيف تعلقين على مشاهدينا من حولك
يعني رحله جديده الى تاريخ مع التواجد
يعني نحن في 2023
وتشعر انك تعود للقرون الوسطى بالكثير من
الرموز والطقوس التي تمارسها على
[موسيقى]
4000 عنصر من القوات المسلحه منذ اسابيع
والجميع يتدرب
به
المسيح
ومنذ الحقود وكان الملك تشارلز ينتظر هذه
اللحظه التاريخيه التي سيتوج فيها ملكا
والمملكه المتحده
العربه المذاهبه التي نراها الان وعمرها
260 عاما هذه العربه الذهبيه وفيها الملك
والملكه خلفه هذه المشاهد للامير هاري نرى
الامير هاري يستقل السياره ويخرج في
السياره ولا يسير من ضمن المسيره مسيره
التتويج الكثير من الدلالات السياسيه ربما
عدسات الكاميرا ايضا التقطتها اذا
الملكيه للملك والملكه هناك
اننا يعني ربما انت تشاهدي هذه اللحظه من
عندك وتنقليها لنارينا لكن نحن الان نشاهد
الموكب وواضح بانه هناك رغبه في التركيز
على هذا الموكب وعدم الانشغال ربما
بالامير هاري باستثناء ربما لقطه او
لقطتين تم اخذهما للامير هاله وبالتالي
نحن هنا لم نشاهدها لم نشاهدنا شاهدتيه
انت بالعين المجرده
لكل من يرى ما امامنا على الشاشه شركات
خاصه تنقل هذا الحدث
وبتعليمات من قصر باكينغهام ولا محطه
تلفزيونيه لبريطانيه ولا عالميه لديها
كاميرات لنقل هذه الحدث ولا تقطيع الصور
هي شركات خاصه تابعه لقصر
وتلتقط الصور التي تريدها ربما لقطه
الاميره هاري جاءت على قناه محليه لا اعلم
ولكن المسيره مسيره التتويج فيها عربه
الملك والملكه خلفهما الاميره ان شقيقه
الملك والاكثر قربا وهناك عربه اولى خلف
الملك وهي عربه ولي العهد وداخل هذه
العربه الاميره كي
وابناء الامير ويليام ولي العهد وهو اولا
الامير جورج وما هو الثالث في تراتبيه
العرش الاميره شارلز والامير لويس وهناك
عربه ثانيه خلف عربه الملك وفيه
[تصفيق]
وفي عربه ثالثه دوك انثى وزوجته وايضا
فايروس ادمر
ثلاث عربات من المفترض ان تسير خلف عربه
الملك وهي مصنوعه من الخشب ومطليه بالذهاب
ومرضعه بالاحجار الكريمه وتحمل الكثير من
الدلالات والتاريخ ريما تابعنا الانباء
الذي تحدثت عن حضور نحو 100 زعيم ورئيس
وزراء
هذا الحفل لكننا لم نلحظ ربما تركيزا على
هؤلاء الذين حضروا ومثلوا 200 دوله حول
العالم
الى اي مدى اهتمت ببريطانيا بان تركز على
هذه اللحظه التاريخيه التي تتعلق بتشارلز
الثالث ملك بريطانيا وايضا هل ربما سنشاهد
هؤلاء الضيوف في قادم الساعات مع انتهاء
هذه المراسم هل اختتمت الاحتفالات في
بريطانيا ام انها ستستمر بشكل اخر
بدات ليل امس وتختتن بشكل نهائي نيل
الاثنين من ناحيه الضيوف وكبار الشخصيات
اقامه الملك ريسبشن او احتفال نيل
واحاديث التي تجري وهي نوع من الدبلوماسيه
دبلوماسيه التتويج بشكل ان بريطانيا تواصل
علاقاتها مع الحلفاء ومع المجتمع الدولي
ومع اي يعني حديث لها في المنطقه وفي
العالم مهم جدا ان نعرف ما هي الاجتماعات
الجانبيه واصلا الخارجيه البريطانيه تحذر
لهذه اللح قبل اشهر واتابع كانت حريصه ان
يكون هناك كبار الشخصيات في بريطانيا ولكن
بامكاني القول انه الحضور لم يكن هناك حرف
من باكينغهام ومن خارجيه كما كان لدى
الدفن دفن الملكه اليزابيث
بشكل كبير ارادوا كبار الشخصيات ولكن بشكل
محدود لانه ارادوا حفر الانفاق نرى
المشاهد وفيها العربه الملكيه المذاهبات
وكمالله موجوده في داخل هذه العربه الى
جانب الملك والجميع في بريطانيا غير صوره
ملك الملكه واصبح
ينقصه حب عمرها 50 عاما وهي حب كامله
والملك تشارلز وبالتالي هذا ربما يحيي الى
سؤال قبل ان نتحدث عن المرحله القادمه انه
هل تغيرت صوره وشعبيه كاملا من عشيقه غير
محبوبه الى ملكه الان وهل ستعزز هذه
المشاهد والمراسم من صورتها لدى
البريطانيين
بشكل كبير واكثر مما تتوقع ابراهيم حتى
سالت انا اشخاص بيعرفوا الملكه كملا قالوا
انها سيده ذكيه جدا محبوبه وعندما تتعرف
عليها تحبها بشكل اكبر البعض يرى انها
كانت مظلومه انها ضحيه سياسات العائله
الملكيه التي ارادت للملك تشارلز عندما
كان وليان بالعهد ارادوا شخصيه مثل
الاميره ديانا من عائله مرموقه بغض النظر
عما اذا كان يحبها ام لا البعض راى انها
ضحيه العائله الملكيه البعض الاخرين بانها
لن تكون محبوبه مثل الاميره ديانا
تمكنت من قلب الراي العام البريطاني وربما
العالمي وصورتها من عشيقه الى ملكه متوجه
محبوبه لديها الكثير من
الميريه والاجتماعيه والثقافيه وهي شخصيه
ذكيه جدا وكل عائلتها موجوده بالتتويج حتى
زوجها السابق واحفاد او ابنائها فقط قبل
ان نعود الى اشباره لو تطلعين الان الى
اين وصل الموكب كم يتوقع ان ننتظر حتى يصل
الملك تشارلز الثالث الى قصر باكينغه من
جديد
على مشارف قصر باكنجهار نرى القوات
المسلحه تقترب من القصر يتوقع ان يقف
الملك والملكه على الشرطه بحلول الثانيه
والنصب بتوقيت لندن يعني بعد ساعه من الان
يصل الملك الى
القصر يتوقع ان تنتهي المسيره خلال ربع
ساعه من الان مع وصول الموكب
كل شيء مدروس لحظه بلحظه وهناك حر ان يكون
هناك اتباع للبرنامج وفقا للدقيقه ومن دون
تاخير ومن خلال متابعات كريمه هل لفت نظرك
اي شيء لم يكن موجودا في البروتوكول
الرسمي هل كان هناك اي استثناءات خصوصا
فيما يتعلق الخروج عن العادات والتقاليد
المتبعه منذ مئات السنين عند تتويج الملك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المسيحي وايضا خرجوا عن بروتوكول الماضي
بحضور ملوك هناك على
داخل الحضور لكن
حافظوا على الكثير من عمق
وتاريخ هذه العائله وهي الرسائل السياسيه
التي تريد العائله الملكيه ان تعطيها
البريطانيا وللعالم ولا ارجاء المملكه
المملكه انها عائله مستمره استمراريه
العرش استمراريه العائله الملكيه مع
الحفاظ على العصرنه وعلى الجانب العصري
لهذه العائله الملكيه نرى القوات المسلحه
والوفد على مشارف
القصريب باركينغهام ومحاط بالحدائق التي
هي عاده الحدائق الموازيه
لقفل بالتاكيد سنعود لكريمه لتطلعين على
كل التفاصيل المتعلقه بالمرحله القادمه من
مراسم التتويج وايضا وقوف الملك تشارلز
على
شرفه قصر باكينغهام ومن سي معه لكن اسمحي
لي الان نعود الى محمد جبار والصحفي من
بريطانيا تحدثت ريما محمد عن هذه
الاستثناءات التي جرت اليوم في مراسم
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث من بينها
تحدثوا في القسم عن حمايه الاديان وايضا
حضور ملوك في هذا التتويج
وحديثه اذا كنت تابعت معي مع ممثلي
الاديان هو وقف والتفت اليهم وتحدث معهم
ما هي الرسائل التي اراد تشارلز ان يوصلها
من خلال كل هذه الاستثناءات التي اصر
عليها
[تصفيق]
يبدو ان الملك تشارلز قد سعى ومنذ يعني
حتى خلال وجوده كوليه العهد للتاكيد على
متابعته بشكل حثيس لكل ما يجري في العالم
هو ما سعى استاذ ابراهيم مباشره ليقوله ان
العالم تغير وبريطانيا تغيرت وهو نتاج هذه
التغيرات هو كان له بعد نظر منذ مكانه
وليا للعهد ولسنوات طويله حينما كان هناك
من يطرح نظريات
نزاع الاديان ونزاع الحضارات كان
الملك تشارلز الثالث عندما كان وليا العهد
يطرح تسامح الاديان يطرح نظريات لطلاق
الثقافات والحضارات وهو
ان كان قد كسر ابرز عرف في القسم الملكي
عندما تقول انه حامي الدين والحارس لهذا
الدين لانه
عمليا رئيس الكنيسه
ولكن ايضا هو قال انه حامي الاديان وحريه
المعتقد وهذا
بشكل او باخر اذا قيمنا شخصيه الرجل
وتوجهات هذا الملك فهي توجهات يعني
متسامحه الى حد كبير هو هو يقرا اللغه
العربيه
عنده علاقه جيده بالعالم العربي وحتى
الثقافه الاسلاميه ويتحدث لغات اخرى غير
الانجليزيه من بين الفرنسيه وبالتالي ما
يفعله نابع من ايمان عميق بمعتقدات وليس
مجرد محاوله لتغيير شكلي في توجه وما
ستذهب اليه المؤسسه الملكيه وبرايك انه
هذا الامر هل سيساعد الملكيه في بريطانيا
على ان تدوم اكثر بحيث انها تتماهى مع
المتغيرات
وما وصلت اليه بريطانيا
من استاذ ابراهيم يعني هو على فكره
الملك تشارلز الثالث يعني مستعد للكثير
ليذهب الى ابعد ما يكون
للتمسك بما يعتبره او ما يؤمن به وما
يعتبره اساسي في حياته هو بشكل او باخر
عبر يعني كان محلا نقد في مرحله من
المراحل الاهتمامه بالبيئه في مراحل اخرى
لاهتمامه بتسامح الاديان والتعدديه او حتى
في مساله
الابنيه وهندستها المع الهندسه المعماريه
كان له راي غير الاراء السائده وهو بقي
متمسكا بها وانا لا اعتقد انه هنا يهادن
احد او يقوم بالتمثيل على احد انها بالفعل
رؤيته وما يؤمن به وبان العالم قد تغير
وان على بريطانيا وايضا اسرتها الملكيه ان
تتغير وانت تتطور اما غدا هل سي محل
انتقادات لانه بدا متسامح اكثر من اللزوم
مع الاديان او قد يؤرق بعض الاوساط
البريطانيه هنا وهناك فهذا ما سنراه ولكن
انا اعتقد انه متمسك بكل ما امن به وما كل
ما هذا الكبير محمد يعني اذا ما كانت
الايام والاسابيع القادمه ربما ستمثل
امتحانا للملك المتوج واذا ما كان يعني
بمقدوره الحفاظ في عهده على المؤسسه
الملكيه لكن دعنا نعود قليلا للحديث عن
هذه الصوره التي نتابعها
هذا المشهد في بريطانيا كما تم الحديث تم
الاعداد له بشكل مسبق هذا مشهد مهم لم
يحدث في بريطانيا منذ 70 عاما تتويج ملك
يبلغ من العمر 74 عاما الملك رقم 40 وهناك
حضور لافت يبدو ان الامور تسير يعني بشكل
جيد كما يقولون ولا غلطه منذ الب دايه
والى الان
لمن يعود الفضل في هذا التنظيم الذي لا
تشوبه شائبه اذا جاز التعبير محمد
يعني سؤال جدا مهم استاذ ابراهيم لان اذا
عرف عن البريطانيون شيء هو تنظيم
الاحتفالات وذلك كي لا تسودها او لا
يشوبها اي شائبه فما بالك بالاحتفالات
الملكيه
انا اتذكر في تسعينات القرن الماضي وكنت
صحفيا
عاملا في الاوساط البريطانيه كان هناك ما
يسمى بايجاز صحفي شهر او فصلي عن كيفيه ما
سيجري في حال توفي احد اركان الاسره
الحاكمه وكان في تلك الفتره ليس الملكه
ولكن الملكه الام وكانت عجوز وكان من
المنتظر يعني بشكل او باخر تعد الدوله
لعده ويعد القصر العده ويبدا بالتدريبات
والتنظيمات كي يوم وقوع مثل هذا الحدث
هناك بلاي بوك هناك دفتر خاص يلجا اليه
وفيه كافه التفاصيل لتنظيفها مبال حفله
تتويج انا اعتقد بالرغم من انه لم يجري
تتويج اي ملك او ملكه منذ 70 عاما لان
الملكه اليزابيث كانت موجوده لكن هذه
الخطط وهذه
التفاصيل والد والتدريبات والاعدادات تسير
بشكل سنوي وبشكل روتيني ضمن المراجع
التنظيميه الخاصه لدى قصر باكينهم
والحكومه البريطانيه وقطاع الخدمه العامه
فهؤلاء ثلاثه اركان من اركان الحكم
البريطاني لا يمكن تناسيها الخدمه العامه
طبعا القصر الملكي وثم الحكومه يعني
الوزراء والوزراء وبالتالي هذا ما نشهده
هو صوره عن القدره التنظيميه الكبيره جدا
لدى الدوله البريطانيه التي لطالما عرفت
واختصت بها
وهو مشهد اذا صح التعبير تاريخي كنا
شاهدنا بمطلع ثمانينات زواج تشارلز يشير
الان يعني الان بشكل كبير الان في هذه
اللحظات
تقترب هذه العربه وست الى قصر باكينغهام
العربه الملكيه المذهبه تدخل ومن خلفها
عربه ولي العهد الامير وليم مع عائلته اذا
ننتظر الان ربما الجزء الثاني
والتالي من هذه المراسم عندما تتم تحيه
الملك والملكه
والهتافات من قبل العسكريين الذين يشاركون
في الموكب الان هذه العربه تدخل الى قصر
باكينغهام
وسيتم تلقي التحيه كما تحدثنا محمد كل شيء
مدروس كل شيء محسوب حتى من راجع جدول هذه
المراسم يلاحظ ان هناك دقه بالدقيقه
وبالتالي الامور محسوبه نستمع الى الصوت
الطبيعي ثم نعود لاستكمال الحديث معك حول
هذه
المراسم المهيبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ريما مكتبي مديره مكتب العربيه في لندن
اجواء ماطره ريما ونحن نشاهد هذه
التشكيلات من الحرس التي تستعد لتحيه
الملك في ساحه القصر لو تطلعين على ما
سيحدث الان
اجواء ماطره او جميع كان يصلي يعني حفل
تتويج خالي من الامطار لكن هذه هي
بريطانيا وهذا طقس
الملك والملكه يتوجهان الان الى الشرفه
الغربيه من قصر باكينغهام وهناك شيء يعرف
بالرويال سالوت او التحيه الملكيه
وثلاثه هتافات من الطقم او طاقم او طواقم
العسكريه الذين كانوا يشاركون في مسيره
التتويج
توجه الى الشرفه الغربيه يتحضر الملك
والملكه
يعني واحده ونص كان متوقع ان يحدث ان يحدث
ذلك وكما قلت باللحظه كل شيء على الوقت
ظهور من الشرطه سيكون ثنتين ونصف بتوقيت
لندن يعني بعد ساعه من الان تقريبا ويظهر
الملك والملكه من الشرطه شرفه قصر
باكنجهام وهي صوره المعتاده التي رايناها
ايضا فعلتها الملك اليزابيث الملكه
اليزابيث عام 1953
وكانت برفقه عائلاتها اذا الان
والتحيه الملكيه من قبل القوات المسلحه
للملك والملكه
ولذلك توجهان الى
الجسر باكينغهام نتوقع ان يكون هناك ايضا
عرضا عسكريا جويا في فوق اجواء العاصمه
والمسافه التي قطعها الملك والملكه تقريبا
اثنين كيلو متر ومن من الى قصر
ويشارك الاف القوات المسلحه في هذه
المسيره 19 فرقه عسكريه
250 حصانا و4,000 فرد من القوات المسلحه
وممثلين عن جيوش 30 دوله على اقل من دول
وانا اتحدث معك ربما احمل في يدي الصوره
التي تم التقاطها وانت تعلميها وتعريفيها
جيدا صوره عام 1953 من الشرفه عندما تم
تتويج نعم هذه الصوره ضمت الملكه اليزابيث
والاميره ان شقيقتها والملكه الام وايضا
الامير فيليب والامير تشارلز والاميره
اليوم من
يتوقع ان يكون موجود على الشرفه مع الملك
تشارلز والملكه كامله
ملكه
ان تكون الملكه الام لانك كانت على قيد
الحياه وافراد
عائله امامها وايضا ولي العهد الان
الملك لديه رسائل مختلفه نعرف ان الاحفاد
سيكونون على الشرطه الملك والملكه ومن
المفترض ان يكون ولي العهد لكن لن نرى كل
افراد العائله التابعه للملك هنا اعني
الامير ويليام سيكون من المستبعد جدا ان
يقف شقيق الملك تشارلز وهو الامير انجلو
الذي احطته الكثير من
الفضاء
قد من
الملك هو للاميره شقيقه الملك بزي العسكري
خلفه
والدور الاكبر من ابناء الملك هو للامير
وليام ولي العهد يحرص الملك شعر ان يعطي
صوره لعائله ملكيه صغيره وفعاله
[موسيقى]
وهذا ما برايه سيحافظ على العائله الملكيه
وعلى عصريه هذه العائله ومواكبتها للعصر
بانتظار ان نشاهد هذه اللحظات نحن نعيد
على مشاهدينا هذه اللحظه التاريخيه لحظه
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه
المتحده عن عمر بلغ اربعه وسبعين عاما
ليصبح الملك رقم 40
لبريطانيا وهو الذي كان طفلا على الشرفه
عندما تم تتويج والدته الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه عام 53 اود ان اسالك عن ماذا يفعل
الملك الان وحتى ظهوره على شرفه قصر
باكينغهام لدينا تقريبا نحو ساعه الى ربع
هل يستريح هل يقوم بتبديل ملابسه ماذا
نعرف عن هذه المده ريم
وسي او خرج من قصر باكينغهام بثوب قرمزي
وخرج ملكا متوجا بثوب مختلف لكل ذلك
دلالات تاريخيه مهمه
سنرى اذا ما كان سيظهر بالثوب وهذا متوقع
هو والملكه من على الشرفه يلتقطون الانفاس
ويعطون الفرصه لالاف القوات المسلحه لدخول
الى قصر باكينغ لاداء التحيه الملكيه ويتم
تجهيز العائله لظهور من امام الشرطه هذا
الوقت تقريبا 45 دقيقه وهو مدروس باللحظه
ويكون الملك قد اصبح جاهزا للوصول من امام
الشعب لكن
سؤال هو الحشود نعم ضرب طوقا اميا كما نرى
من امام او منحاول قصر باتنهام للسماح
للقوات المسلحه وتامين الملك وصوله بشكل
سليم
الان ربما ستفتح الطرقات ليقترب الناس من
القصر بشكل مدروس وبشكل امني مدروس عدسات
الكاميرا الواسعه
يعني تشير الى ان حدائق القصر خاليه من
الناس
وايضا
الطرقات الموازيه سمح لعدد قليل من الناس
بان يتواجدوا فيها وذلك للحفاظ على الشق
الامني وسلامه الملك هذه اكبر عمليه امنيه
تقوم بها بريطانيا ربما في هذا في هذا
العام طبعا العمليه
الوفاه الملكه اليزابيث ايضا كانت عمليه
امنيه ضخمه واليوم ايضا وبالتالي هنا ربما
هناك الكثير من التقنيات التي وضع
ت في الضباط ورجال الامن
للحفاظ على شعبيه
تتويج مع الحفاظ على سلامه الملك والحضور
والمدعو بالتاكيد سنعود معك لمتابعه كل ما
يستجد فيما يتعلق بهذه الاحتفالات بعد
تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث نعطيك بعض
الوقت لما ثم نعود لك لتعلقي لنا على
الصوره والحدث من لندن وتحديدا منتصر
واسمح لي ان اعود من جديد لمحمد شبارو كنا
نتحدث عن التنظيم قبل ان نتحول الى مديره
مكتب العربيه في لندن لاست انه ايضا عندما
قبل وفاه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه كانت
الانباء تشير الى انها هي من اشرفت على
تنظيم جنازتها وهذا امر لافت ان يقوم
انسان بالاعداد لجنازته وكل التفاصيل
المتعلقه بها الى اي مدى بريطانيا ربما
لديها
ربما حساسيه شديده تجاه الكمال
ولو ان الكمال غير موجود لكن لماذا يسعون
الى الكمال في كل شيء حتى عندما يتعلق
الامر بوفاه ملكه او تتويج ملك
السؤال جدا مهم استاذ ابراهيم وربما
الاجابه عليه معقده بعض الشيء ولكن اعتقد
ان كل ذلك يتعلق بالثقافه والشخصيه
البريطانيه طبعا الكمال مفقود ولكن
التخطيط هو جزء من الاعداد وهو جزء من
احترام القضيه هو جزء من ايضا التعاطي بان
يوما ما بواقعيه عندما اهتمت الملكه
بتنظيم جنازتها وتفاصيلها ايضا كانت
واقعيه بانها انسانه ويوما ما
سترحل عن هذا العالم وهنا اعتقد يعني مكمن
القضيه كلها اليوم حتى الملكه تشارلز قام
بوضع لمساته على خطه تنصيبه وتتويجه وهو
يعني موجود الفرق والمسؤولين والخبراء
والرسميين المسؤولين عن هذه المهام ولكن
ايضا
[موسيقى]
في العالم ولذلك نرى ما نراه يعني اليوم
شبه لوحه فنيه اذا صح التعبير الموسيقى
اختارها الملك ايضا هناك معدين موسيقى
كبار قد قاموا بتاليف هذه المقطوعات قبل
ربما سنوات انه عندما يتم تتويجكم انا
اقدم لكم هذه المقطوعه ربما عبر الازمنه
ايضا كان هذا الامر يعني يحدث ولكن اعتقد
بالنسبه لبريطانيا ياخذ مرتبه اخرى ومكانه
اعلى من التنظيم والترتيب والاعداد لافته
محمد يعني الكثير من الزملاء هنا كانوا
يمنون النفس الذهاب الى لندن لمتابعه هذه
الاحتفاليه والمراسب عن كتب وهذا يعكس
اهميه الصوره واهميه ما تقدمه بريطانيا
للعالم على صعيد ربما عكس حضارتها
واستقطاب مزيد من السياح الارقام تتحدث عن
مليار استرليني ستعود على بريطانيا بسبب
هذا التتويج هذا لا يقارن بحجم ما ستصرف
الحكومه وبالتالي هل يمكن القول بان هناك
توازن بينما يتم انفاقه على هذه المراسم
المتعلقه بالمؤسسه الملكيه وبين ما تدره
على خزينه الدوله يعني اعتقد ابراهيم
اجبتم عن يعني وضعتم السؤال واجبتم عنه
يقال ان كلفه هذه الاحتفاليه تصل تصل الى
مئه مليون جنيه استرليني او تقريبا هذا
هذا الرقم وانا اعتقد انه اقل بكثير من
ذلك ولكن هذا هو الرقم الذي افصح عنه لدى
الدوائر والمراجع المختصه ثم تحدثتم عن
مليار من العائدات والعوائد فهو يعني عشر
مرات الكلفه وبالتالي اعتقد اذا ان
النتيجه التجاريه محسومه اذا صح التعبير
هنا ولكن لابد السؤال يعني اذا اذا كانت
الامور محسومه بهذه الطريقه لماذا تخرج
اصوات تقول بانه ليس على دافع الضرائب
البريطانيين ان يتحملوا مسؤوليه هذه
المظاهر
والبرجوازيه
وكل ما يتم الحديث عنه ونحن نشاهد الان
بالصوره هذا التاج وايضا المرصع بالمساه
ربما
2868 الماسه وسبعه عشر حفر حجر زفير كل
هذا يقول بانه لماذا يتكبد هو هذه
المصاريف في وقت تعيش فيه بريطانيا
الدائقه لماذا ليس هناك وعي وفهم لدى
المواطن البريطاني بان هذه الصوره
والمؤسسات تدر ربما دخلا وتعكس صوره جميله
عن بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نعود الى مديره مكتب العربيه
ريما مكتبي ريما كما توقعت تم تحيه الملك
وثلاثه هتافات من العسكريين الذين شاركوا
في الموكب دون وجود حشود من الحضور تحدثين
اكثر عن تفاصيل مشاهدتي وشاهدناه معك هنا
اود ان الت عنايه المشاهدين انها القوات
المسلحه البريطانيه وايضا دول الكومنويل
وليس فقط البريطانيه
تقريبا يعني على الاقل 30 دوله من دول
الكومنويل بقواتها المسلحه ممثله في هذه
التحيه لانه ملك متوج على هذه الدول ايضا
اضافه الى القوات المسلحه البريطانيه
نتحدث عن 19 فرقه عسكريه متواجده على
الارض لتحيه الملك خرج بشكل يعني
سريع الى الشرفه لتلقي التحيه وهو نوع من
اعلان الولاء للملك هذا نوع من اعلان
الولاء وهو البيع للملك الجديد من قبل
القوات المسلحه البريطانيه ودول
الكومنويل ولافت وجود الاحفاد
عدسه الكاميرا يعني لم نرى ولي العهد ما
بعرف اذا كان موجود ولكن الاحفاد موجودين
خلف الملك والى جانبه الملكي وهنا اود ان
اذكر بان حتى عدسات الكاميرا التي تلتقط
هذا الحدث من لحظه دخول خروج الملك من
باكيهام الى وصوله لكنيسه مانستر وعودته
الى باكيهام كلها من ضمن شركات خاصه تابعه
لقصر هي تقرر الصوره هي تقرر اللقطه وهي
تقرر على من ستسلط الضوء خلال هذا الحفل
كل شيء مدروس وايضا هذا يدخل طبعا من ضمن
تكاليف موضوع التتويج الان عدا الامير
هاري في هذه الاثناء
للجدليه لانه رايناه يدخل
يعني يدخل الى سياره خرج من الكنيسه ودخل
الى السياره وذهب
ليس وضع باكينغهام او الى المطار وكان
جالسا داخل الكنيسه الى جانب الامير اندرو
الكثير من الدلالات السياسيه
بهذا الشكل تقول لعائله الملكيه انه كل
الجدل الذي رافق الامير هاري والامير
انجرو
تستمع العائله الملكيه للشعب ولاراء
لحظات ونعرف اذا ما كان الامير هاري جاء
الى باكمام او تسافر الى خارج البلاد ولكن
اصبح في ضوء او تحت مجهر الصحافه الصفراء
من لحظه
صعوده السياره بعد انتهاء اذا لاحظت ريما
معنا
لحظه اداء التحيه كان الملك تشارلز الثالث
يبتسم ولو انه كان يحاول الاخفاء ابتسامه
لكن كانت تبدو عليه السعاده وكانه يقول
اخيرا حانت اللحظه
بتذكر ابراهيم يوم وفاه الملكه وعندما
اصبح ملكا يوم اعلانه ملك كنا بقصر
قصر فنجان وهو قصر التاريخي لندن فيما كان
يوقع على الورقه كان متوتر بعض الشيء وطلب
ازاحه الحبر كي لا يلطخ ثوبه وهذه
او هذه او هذا التصرف التقطه التقطته
وسائل الاعلام بشكل سلبي بعض
العائله الملكيه تعرف جيدا ان اي خطوه
مدروسه اي بسمه اي تصرف اي علامه على
الوجه يعني هم اصلا مدربون على هكذا لحظات
من يوم اللي بيخلقوه من ضمن العائله
الملكيه
جميع افراد العائله الملكيه يخضعون
لتدريبات
تعليمات على الاتباع البروتوكول وانا
لاحظت مثل ما انت لاحظت ابراهيم طوال
الاحتفال بقي الملك تشارلز مبتسما لم يريد
ان يعطي صوره بانه متوتر او خائف او متردد
اعطى صوره انه الملك الحازم الحنون
والواثق من نفسه
وحرصه الذي يظهر بمظهر مشابه للذي حصل
اثناء التوقيع يوم اللي اعلن عنه ملك لحظه
وفاه الملك شكرا لك ستبقين معنا خلال
تغطيتنا المستمره على قناه لتتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث ملك المملكه المتحده وايضا
الشكر موصول لمحمد اشباره الذي كان معنا
وسيبقى معنا خلال هذه التغطيه التي
امضينا معكم فيها اكثر من ثلاث ساعات في
بث حي ومباشر لمتابعه كل وادق التفاصيل
التي رافقت تتويج الملك تشارلز والملكه
كاميليا ولحظه وصولهم من قصر باكينغهام
الى كنيسه
والتتويج والعوده وكل ما رافق ذلك من
مراسم الان نحن بانتظار ان يصعد الملك
تشارز الثالث والملكه كاميليا على شرفه
قصر لتحيه الموجودين التغطيه مستمره على
قناه العربيه على راس الساعه مع الزميل
نايف الاحمري تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
برامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات